best remaining free agents we've talked
too much today so we don't have a whole
lot of time chris you're up first best
remaining free agents 2021 well listen
there's injury concern here right we
know that i don't know if this is
anything that's going to happen anytime
soon but it's a guy that's 28 years old
and still has tremendous upside now it's
a weird year i don't know but gideon
clowney is still going to be one of the
top guys out there for my money i mean
yeah it's a position that we know has
great importance in the nfl and edge
rusher and edge defender all together
he's extremely versatile yeah there's
the injury risk and all that i don't
know what he's asking for money-wise i
would imagine we're gonna be in another
one-year deal type of thing but clowney
just too much of a physical freak to not
make him number one at least for me
right now
or wait like he did last year remember
there was the genevieve and clowney
derby near the end of the year as teams
figured out how best to properly fit him
under a salary cap although i remember
last year one of the problems was teams
couldn't bring him in and kick the tires
and take a look they can this year uh
given where the pandemic currently is
i'll go mitchell schwartz cut by the
chiefs multiple time all pro not just
pro bowler but all pro salary cap move
he's out there he's available bring him
in check him out if he's healthy he's a
guy that you need on your offensive line
period i'm still surprised that the
chief's moved on from him i i am too you
know i mean it's one of those where it
just it makes you wonder how serious is
the back what is what is the absolute
you know issue there uh that's i i
thought about taking him number one too
i just i got a little scared i guess
with with that aspect of it all um
i'm gonna throw out melvin ingram
another edge defender you know again i
don't i think his days of being a
superstar yeah they're they're over i
understand that but and i know he was
hurt a little last year too
but again i think like clowney it's just
it's too much of a physical freak and
there's too much good that i've seen on
film over the last few years so i mean
just to give up on a guy like that now
again it might have to be about the
market correcting itself and that kind
of thing but i think for somebody who
signs up melvin ingram i mean defense
and outside linebacker can do everything
you know takes on the run can rush the
passer uh for me he's one of the guys i
got to take here he's still a damn good
player
i'm going to stay with the offensive
line and i'm surprised alejandro
villanueva remains
unclaimed by anyone a guy who who has a
great
leadership background from his time in
the military and and rose up gradually
and consistently to become a key
contributor on the steelers offensive
line there was a time not that long ago
but the steelers offensive line was
horrible then it became very good and
villanueva was one of the main reasons
for it i'm surprised a week in he's
still available when we consider the
importance of you know we can look at
the super bowl and say
pass rush is so critical we can also
look and say blocking is pretty critical
too because the chiefs were completely
over matched that day so uh surprising
that villanueva is still available i
thought the broncos would find a spot
for him somewhere because mike munshack
the former offensive line coach in
pittsburgh is now in denver yeah no i
hear you uh i mean it is surprising that
nobody has gobbled him up yet you know
again the thing that was concerning just
watching him and evaluate him a little
bit you know there is a little slippage
in play you know it's just there was a
few too many times where you see him get
pushed back into the quarterback's face
you know he's such a tall guy he has a
hard time getting low and driving people
out in the run game a little bit maybe
those are the concerns let alone the age
and you know again i think a lot of
these like veteran guys who have placed
an old timer 32
that i know is old
i know that's what's crazy in the nfl i
mean that's crazy but i think a lot of
these old-timers and these guys though
are
you know they're going to sit back and
kind of just get a feel for the market
and where can i go and where is my
needed and all of those type of things
i'm going to go with t.y hilton here
next i mean
i don't think there's a better receiver
on the market as we sit here right now
you know last year he wasn't a hundred
percent he played in you know i think he
played in 15 games but i don't think he
was totally 100 and a good amount of
them but still has like ability to where
i go oh i'd want him on my team i'd want
him as one of my three receivers right
now it still can win on the outside
could play the slot you know has
explosive ability still to make big
plays down the field too so i'll go with
ty hilton as my third pick
i'll go carlos dunlap with my last one
uh you know he was cut in a cap move by
the seahawks he's out there i know
there's a lot of pass rushers that have
been signed well there's some that
haven't been you mentioned clowney
earlier i think dunlap another guy that
teams have to take seriously part of the
dynamics at this point may simply be
when you call the agent and you ask what
the player is looking for the team just
says okay see you and they're waiting
for the expectations to go to drop right
and the passage of time will eventually
cause guys i think to take less and and
this was something shereen williams
suggested before free agency started
will there be guys who just either wait
until september or just say i'll wait
till next year i i i think there's a
real risk though in taking a year off
the game moves on without definitely and
it's not like you're going to find more
money next year unless you're a
superstar you're not going to find more
money next year if you consciously sit
out this year simply because the cap's
down agreed i agree i think you're doing
yourself a disservice you might be able
to get away with that as a college kid
like we saw jamar chase and some of
those guys because they're still like
physically going in the upward direction
it's no big deal but once you've gone
like through five or six years in the
nfl you're going in the other direction
and now you only have a certain amount
of years left in your playing career so
to sit out does not make sense but yeah
i think you make a good point hey i had
karim jackson you know this casualty
from the broncos i maybe should have
picked him olivier vernon another edge
guy who's real good and i even think
malcolm butler and dominic and sue
there's some guys out there that still
can help a lot of football teams
aj bouier's still floating around that's
right uh did you mention kj
wright available too so still plenty of
great guys more than a week since the
market opened and there'll be plenty of
activity there's been a few moves today
just as the show's been almost
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports